comme
réunis ici pour faire front nous voulons
faire front déterminer contre cette
réforme que nous qualifions de réforme
de régression sociale nous allons nous
battre
la pas échappé avec nous étions
minoritaire au sein du Sénat mais nous
serons une opposition
déterminée nous battre contre cette
réforme qui traduit finalement
l'entêtement d'un gouvernement et aussi
l'endettement du président de la
République à faire passer en force
contre manifestement une très grande
majorité des Français une réforme que
nous qualifions d'injuste et oui elle
n'est pas juste parce que le report de
l'âge légal pénalisera en particulier
celles et ceux qui ont des carrières
hachées ou des métiers pénibles et
notamment d'abord les femmes
elle n'est pas utile parce que ce régime
n'est pas de répartition n'est pas on
n'est pas menacé il n'est pas en
faillite et s'il faut trouver un
meilleur équilibre financier et bien
pourquoi toujours demander au même au
plus grand nombre et au plus modeste de
contribuer à cet effort financier nous
aurons l'occasion de défendre de
nombreux amendements pour montrer qu'une
autre voix est possible et puis je tiens
à rappeler que souvent le gouvernement
nous dit mais ça ne concernera entre que
si Français sur dix mais quand vous
faites le calcul c'est si Français sur
dix c'est 18 millions 18 millions de de
Français qui seront concernés des
Français actifs et puis c'est très fort
mais les bricoler et après discussion à
la semaine nationale et à force de faire
des concessions et bien la réforme qui
devait avoir un rendement financier le
mot de rendement financier celui utilisé
régulièrement par la première ministre
de 18 milliards il ne serait plus
aujourd'hui que de 10 ou ou 12 milliards
d'euros donc le gouvernement met un pays
institution de blocage pour un enjeu
financier qui est qui est mineur alors
Mesdames et Messieurs nous porterons
aussi avec nos collègues une motion
référendaire l'objectif étant pour nous
de dire aux Français puisque c'est votre
avenir qui est en cause et bien on va
vous consulter on veut vous consulter et
cette notion sera présentée sans toute
vraisemblance vendredi matin au nom des
trois groupes de gauche qui la signeront
donc nous refais ons nous refusons cette
réforme comptable parce que nous pensons
que c'est un enjeu de société qui aurait
mérité une autre préparation